we live in a more connected age than
ever but also a more distracting age
than ever and you address this idea in
the attention economy where you argue
that it's not an Information Age
actually the real currency is attention
I think for someone like me who wants to
be highly productive I think for a lot
of people the question is how do you
harness technology without suffering the
drawbacks of so many media sites being
so good at drawing you in drawing you in
fortnight
sure anything the you have any solutions
are not all that clear I think they
depend on from person to person
because so much of it is habitual like I
don't use Facebook anymore but without a
doubt you know every couple days I'll
type FA into my search bar and it will
autofill Facebook and I'll hit enter I
didn't choose to do that my habitual
brain FA Facebook how do we get out of
those habits is the harder question lang
Act I I think it's really a balance like
can a service that requires your
attention to survive also be beneficial
to you and do things that don't grab
your attention so like can snapchat make
the decision to kill streaks because
they ruin teenagers lives you know what
I mean like streaks is made to grab them
off annual attention right and have them
keep sending things to their friends yes
what a disaster in terms of you know
having a kid put their phone down right
so it's really up to the the services
it's not that up to you
I believe that very firmly I think they
have grasped how easy it is to exploit
human psychology now that you aren't
really in control the only things that
you can really know I am dead serious
the only things that you can really do
are to turn it off that's what I've done
has turned things off so for example I
don't have that I don't have browser on
my phone anymore so that I can't search
anything and like it's restrict you can
delete your browser you can restrict it
yeah and you can always enter the
passcode to unrestricted sure but I
think by deleting the habitual sideswipe
press and when you swipe and it's not
there your brain is like oh I won't do
it you know what I mean yeah same thing
goes for your interrupting actually
interrupting the pattern in their power
of habit
yeah doing the routine yeah there's the
well actually you're interrupting a the
cute need the trigger the trigger here
you're interrupting the cue so yeah in
the power of habit which is a great book
yeah
got what's what's his Charles doing
Charles doing yeah he talked about
there's the trigger the routine and in
the reward and you basically have to cut
off I believe you have to change the
routines right yeah so so but but before
you can change the routine you have to
figure out what the cue and the reward
are no because if like I think the
example he uses from himself as at work
I every day I would get up and go get a
cookie and then I when I got up I got to
socialize with my coworkers and then I
get to sit down he wanted to get rid of
getting the cookie part he realized that
the only reason he actually got up was
because he wanted to talk to his
co-workers and take a social break so
instead he replaced the routine with I
just got triggered to go get a cookie
instead of getting that cookie I'm going
to go socialize with my co-workers
someone who's free whatever yep and then
I get the same reward so the I guess his
idea of changing a habit is keep the cue
and the reward the same but consciously
change the routine yeah yeah I've done
it I've done something like that with
soda it's like cut it into club soda
right yeah yeah it's like you still get
that the fizziness you get all that kind
of stuff and people look at you like and
it's not that good and compared to water
that's true but as a replacement for our
sorry compared to soda that's true but
it's like a replacement for is a
replacement for it
pretty good yeah so this is a great what
Seltzer is very different from club soda
and scoter wants you to know that yeah
that's there's way better than some so
that those guys talked about so but the
original question was like how how does
someone change the habit how does
someone who wants to work right now I
can't distract death totally uh I think
a big thing is is you need to change
your environment so I think a lot of
people see this willpower thing which is
the wrong way to frame in mm-hm
so a lot of a lot of you know gurus will
say like you just need the willpower to
change your thing which is like I guess
there's some there's some willpower to
stuff I get it but I think there's
nothing more powerful than your
environment so if you can change an
aspect of your environment like let's
say I notice when I'm writing a script
that you know every time I take a break
I go down a hole of twitter and then all
the sudden I'm out of it 45 minutes
later then maybe instead I should go
write in a coffee shop and see if the
environment helps at all I think
environmental triggers are huge because
when you change the environment you
change
the cue like the cue isn't the same if
you're in a different environment yep
that's a big thing well that's the
answers that I wanted to get at because
the having like putting it all on the
app or the service is you're probably
right that as far as like for most
people
nothing's gonna change until the app
changes I agree with that however that
leaves like me or somebody at home who's
like really desperate to like oh I need
to focus more or you know whatever just
kind of like the song they are really
trapped yeah because you know the but
you can make meaningful change by
yourself but you won't have like a
complete unless you're gonna become like
a Luddite and have this phone and my
well so this isn't my idea but there's
the idea of batching but you have to get
in the habit of batching which is to say
like in the morning after you complete
your routine or whatever you bat your
emails then that's the only time you get
to check your email or you could do it
twice a Disher
a lot of the problems people have is
like the consistent I'm every time I get
a text and get a few what it is or every
time I get an email I gotta make sure I
see what it is instead what you should
do is split it into two times per day
where you're like this is the only time
I'm gonna have to do it all the other
times I'm not allowed to do this and
that is a huge help because most emails
and most texts totally do not need to be
answered right away right like if what
you can tell your family is like the
only way I'm gonna pick you need to call
me if there's like an emergency because
I feel like a lot of people are worried
that if I keep it over there for eight
hours while I do work something I could
miss out on like something really bad
right just make sure that you're the
people who regularly contact you know
that you are from whatever 10:00 to 5:00
p.m.
or doing intense work and sorry your
phone's gonna be off or your phone's not
gonna be close to you there's no problem
with saying that you know there's no
problem with doing that and then again
with the emails like do it at 10 do it
at 6
that's it like there's no reason why an
email between 6 and 10 the next day
needs to be answered unless like you
you're running one and I think and I
think a lot of people too they have like
habits of like checking Twitter all the
time they're checking to see if they go
that's my patient Twitter I'm I'm bad
about Twitter I'm also bad about YouTube
because there's onion yeah I'm on
YouTube so I have as big of a YouTube
from Twitter is a big problem novelty
new ideas always yeah yeah I guess I
could explain what I do I don't know if
it would be helpful for people sure no
come on give us what you do like well ok
if you're a computer guy or girl got to
get rid of that habit if your computer
person if you're a computer person if
you're a computer person you want to use
rescuetime it's I can't remember how
much it costs you're gonna have to spend
money on it but it keeps track of all
your usage is it an apposite to software
it's software it's it's on your computer
ok and I keep track of everything keeps
track of your use of video games your
use of Adobe programs your use of the
internet and what sites you go to and so
and then it has a ai or maybe it's just
you know chosen by humans and you can
edit this too is it has a productive
scale from negative 2 to 2 to being very
productive negative to being very
distracting and I don't think there's
anything more effective than at the end
of the week getting an email from
RescueTime saying you spent 21 hours on
entertainment this week and you spent 30
hours on work on design
composition or what they have and you're
at the end of the week you say oh my
gosh like I didn't without knowing it I
played video games went on Twitter and
watched a movie enough time to be just
short of how much tide worked you know
what I mean my god man you and when you
see that in front of you I think that's
a great way to just be like okay yeah
because for a lot of people it's like
they don't know that they're doing well
you're better than having time yeah yeah
I did a I did a thing for a while it
became like it was a lot of upkeep but I
had this a really rigorous time
management system where like I tracked
and last every lasted for like several
months acidly actually lasted a while
because especially when I first started
like doing YouTube I was like I was
determined not to get sidetracked until
I basically from the time I woke up to
the time that I went to bed and I know
these like buckets for like what
classified as you know work what class
fight is over and that was totally
eye-opening to do the same thing and I
would have like weekly progress reports
and like right now but it became to two
companies I like I like a software that
is does before it does it for you
exactly uh the one thing is is how does
it know if like let's say I have Adobe
open but I'm not using it it's only
windows it's act it's only active it
notice in those that you're being act I
want it yeah so like you could have
Spotify open and Adobe open but it's
only gonna keep track of Adobe if you're
perfect if it's fine if I was playing in
the back right and if I go and I click
on Lego I'm gonna go check Twitter or
whatever and I still have Adobe on the
other screen it's gonna count yeah so
what it does in that regard is like it
will measure out the productive versus
distracting so it could register like a
neutral half-hour where like you were
doing Adobe but you're also going on
Twitter and you also check like changing
your Spotify songs it would determine
based on I don't know complicated stuff
that for this half-hour you actually
weren't being
productive it does it's like keep track
of like this half hour you were only
using it only now do they have that for
the phone I don't know I I haven't used
it for the phone my because because my
problem isn't the phone my problem is
the work space right I'm sure other
people have bigger problems with the
phone you know I have a bigger problem
with the workspace personally yeah but I
know I am the person like I know other
people who have much bigger problems
with phone than their computer my
problem is the computer if if anybody
has a problem with the phone there's a
great app called freedom which is like
it's just an internet blocker so you can
go like oh I want to be blocked for 30
minutes or an hour or whatever it'll
sync up to your computer too and you can
do like all sorts of like social block
sites but I like I like this rescue Tom
I haven't heard of it before
rescue times great and they have great
support because there's an element of
reflection involved which I really like
right yeah you manage massively you
don't need you don't need to be like
even if you know you're getting
distracted like you're not gonna cause
like for example let's say you run
freedom and you just want to be
distracted that week what you're just
not gonna run freedom that week right I
mean where's rescue time it's like just
passive so it'll report on your bad
behavior as well right and just be like
okay you should probably should get it
together as far as like right you need
to look at you need to assess yourself
and make a change but like it is
eye-opening to be like oh I didn't
realize I spent 50 hours playing
fortnight this week do you think it ho
big time nice oh yeah so that's like a
big thing for you
yeah rescue times huge and then there's
another one which I bet is not for
everybody but it's called be minder
which is why it's it just is loss
aversion psychology so it's like if you
don't hit a certain you know goal
beeminder charges you so it's money loss
aversion I mean I think for the most
part in terms of getting getting goals
completed the two biggest things that
psychologists say our social proud
and and and loss of her like money like
losing money I've so the idea of like
the idea of like having to pay beeminder
$5,000 if you don't complete your novel
in two years gets people to write their
novels you know that means like it's
terrifying
yeah so how do they know to like so to
give us so you could you could you could
set something as simple as I want
beeminder to link up with my to-do list
and you can set novel due December 21st
and then you can email beeminder and be
like this is the hard date I am NOT
allowed to check this box on my to-do
list app until that date like you need
to prove like b-minor is that good like
their support will be like no you're a
little weasel and you're just gonna hit
the box yeah yeah yeah that's what I was
wondering uh and complete it and so our
systems gonna update right but you can
also tell them I'm not allowed to do
that and and they will make sure that
you stay that's almost like a notary or
something like that well it's just it's
pressure it's it's actual pressure and
that's one of that's one of the things
that people have such trouble with is
like they try all these different things
and then they are not culpable is that
the right word yeah yeah they're not
they're not responsible and then they
just if an all-gay waive responsibility
if it doesn't go well and so is it like
in terms of getting stuff done if you're
self-employed that's a big one
so beeminder is great like I I think
loss aversion is a huge way to get stuff
done and that's a good program to use it
and it links up with all different stuff
like to-do lists if you want to get if
you can link it with RunKeeper so yeah
like if you want to run out how many
miles you want to run ten miles a week
yeah and you can connect it with B minor
and said if I don't run ten miles this
week be minors gonna charge me whatever
whatever you're not willing to lose
that's a good app like in conjunction
with other other paying atten apps yeah
and I guess it's just it's really sad
that we have to do this like don't you
think that we have to like have
additional apps to help us do these
things no in some ways I think super
important that those apps get developed
because no it's important that they
exist I'm what I'm saying is like it
sucks that we have to use them like cuz
otherwise we'd like to sit here and not
do the things like even if even if you
really want it to do something like
write a movies right so a good chance
you're not gonna do it there's still a
good chance even though you're
passionate about that that you're not
going to do right well we're just unable
to think about long-term goals all the
time and keep their weight in mind right
and so it's like I think you may have
mentioned this earlier about we have
hardware that doesn't fit what we're
using the tools that we're using and
it's like the tools that we're using are
so distracting and so good at always
having something novel like kind of an
maybe more interesting to writing your
screenplay or you know all these things
and so it's like you need software
that's on your side as well like on your
long-term goal side right yeah again
it's the interfacing ancient interface
with brand new thing that takes
advantage of ancient interface
well yeah I'm really looking forward to
like I feel like I feel like the
Internet is basically like a fire hose a
fire hydrant of information basically
you're sure you're not going to retain
at all and you have the input of maybe
just like a normal drink of water and so
part of that is like let's lower the
output and I'm like I need software to
do that for me I want software to filter
out sweat video this is unpopular yeah
yeah yeah but filter out all the noise
to get to a nice little nectar of what I
want yeah yeah yeah yeah and that's also
why it's important to just turn it off
and read a book as well
but I totally agree with that analogy
it's like you can only drink so much
water coming from a fire well yeah I've
got I've actually got a better one
because I realized you need a good
example for resistors like with
electricity something is only useful if
you can get it to the voltage that your
thing needs like most right most don't
need 120 volts so a big part of all you
know boards are resistors to like step
it down to whatever how much you need
and so it's the resistors part that yeah
it the resistor well I think that's an
important point because so many people
don't spend the time to create that
infrastructure to in order to create
those points of resistance and so they
just keep doing the same thing and it's
worth spending a week a month
narrowing closing the gap until you're
at that point at which point you can
more or less take your hands off of it
and accept what you've got right but if
you never create that infrastructure
you're gonna continue to just peel them
like bombarded with infinite information
and yeah and probably retain none of it
[Laughter]
[Music]